this is a production of cornell
university
propagate ventures uh i guess we'll
we'll dive right in first this is this
is a photo looking down a windbreak
which is also an irrigation canal
but it's it's one of our favorites uh
most
all of these photos we've taken across
different farms
in different states and countries and
whatnot so
any questions just maybe write them down
and happy to dive in there
but agenda for the day we'll go into an
overview of how we work as a business
that's our general pitch
um we'll we'll look at a product demo
or analysis snapshot will review over
yield as a concept so how
trees and crops together are more
productive than managing them separately
um throw up a few agroforestry farms in
the finger lakes and then we'll look at
what's been recently introducing
and what's upcoming
so ag and farming
get a whole lot of attention in the news
in the climate change discussion um and
they've really become a focal point
and so often we see images like this um
this is actually
former amazon or amazon land um
and we want to move this at least to the
onset
towards something more like this so
agroforestry
um it's a super old concept it's kind of
weed and popular serious just a current
iteration of that
and it's it's known to be about
40 times excuse me 40 percent more
productive
than i guess traditional agriculture
and we'll dive into how that works in a
little bit uh but
say if agroforestry were incorporated
onto a fraction of u.s farmland
that the carbon data looks like
those is offsetting about 10
of annual emissions u.s annual emissions
every year
and with returns at or below far
five percent uh farmers are looking for
alternatives
like apples chestnuts and timber
but it's it's not necessarily easy
to add tree crops to farmland because
there are operational
business and financial challenges in the
way
and what we've chosen to do is address
these obstacles which
it really unlocks farmland ag
productivity
and investment potential um for third
parties looking to invest
in reject
and specifically agriculture and this so
this is really what angellist did for
startups and wonder capital did for
solar
um if y'all are looking for some analogs
to our business model
all right so i guess uh i can i can walk
you through how
um we look at farms um
this is a design for about 200 acres of
chestnuts and elderberry
and hardwood timber in tennessee um
and what makes it unique
we're not investing in just not just
forestry or just kind of
um r d as an end into itself but
actually owning trees
on land along
ride commercial fans accepting trees
from the land itself as
bankable assets so to walk you through
how we do it
it starts with de-risking farms so folks
apply and run through an analysis
process
and who could ever
within a context of how a farm operates
so we use the holistic management
framework from the savory institute
uh to look at you know what is what do a
set of land managers want out of their
lives
and land and from there we look into
costs revenues yields
and labor assumptions so just a few
slides on those we use financial metrics
like
npv
value internal rate of return et cetera
kind of traditional financial analysis
to really just elucidate how
um agroforestry adds financial value to
the land
so revenue for different crops
labor something interested in um
it's not just how much how many dollars
it takes to manage the system but how
many people
is it going to take to operationalize
that farm
um if it's say 20 people for an for an
apple orchard
um that could flip down to one or two
people if it's a timber system
so context alignment there we qualify
projects and then group to
group them into funds which are
diversified across crop types
and geographies so
funds cohorts that de-risk each other
and once farms are qualified
connect them with investors and
commercial
buyers which is a key part of getting
all of these
fruit nut and timber crops to market and
then
profit share partnership between farmers
land managers and investors
and then this this is our uh this is our
team up until very recently we actually
have audrey on the call
as well uh she's our new director of
business development and then we'll
have three more people um so up to a
team of seven
joining us by february
and so just uh succinctly um
recap that agroforestry econ data
analytics
project development tools so brokering
needs and trees needed to meet
investment expectations
um de-risking tree crops and connecting
land managers to financing to scale
agroforestry into a cornerstone of
agriculture
so i'm going to switch applications now
just jump into a snapshot so
here's a farm in hudson new york it's
about four hours from
ithaca or three and a half or four it's
on 120 acres total 50 acres open this is
mostly a chestnut and black currant
combo polyculture
uh so zoom in here
um orange rows or chestnuts purple rose
or black current
everything else are things like black
locust curly poplar
or biodiversity um see if the graphs
load if they don't um
i guess we can imagine them no i guess
google is uh slowing down how fast they
push
graphs to um
to notion and other external um programs
but we'll go through
total capital required to bring a system
to break even
uh cumulative earnings internal rate of
return and pv which we'll work through
later
um cash flows
uh the discount rate that we use for the
npv full-time land manager so how many
full-time equivalent positions how many
jobs
a certain project is going to create we
actually just did an analysis
for an organization down in pennsylvania
that's looking at water quality and what
would
scaling profitable agroforestry based
riparian buffers look like
um and that the number of jobs that um
scaled up just riparian management and
say elderberry processing would create
was was super interesting to dive into
um this site was fallow for four years
so we
moonscaped it once um and then planted
cover crop just to
kick back the sycamore and the goldenrod
and whatnot
um row mulched everything
um with hardwood bark and so
it's all organic protocol um we're
pretty keen on
the uptick in in price from organic
products
and whatnot um and then another thing
we're doing
is using raked hay as
as mulch so growing in situ biomass um
and i think with that we should
jump back into um
the keynote we can return to all those
um other concepts in a while or
in a little bit maybe in the q a um so
back to over yield as a concept
um it's really one of our favorite words
uh to describe because
how do you have over yield that's it's
um
it's a good one so the 140 percent
statistic
um it's kind of
uh razor so we're going to done what
that means
plantation forestry on the left so
that's just trees
grain base tag on the right just grain
both canopies are
d um what we want to do is take
advantage of the vertical space with
agroforestry
so here if they're just harvested alone
um on the left that's a
popular plantation i visited in oregon
it was about 17 000 acres
of just wood and these these figures are
just
um for t
today's purposes if an acre of wood
yields 100 units of wood
and an acre of wheat yields 100 units
[Music]
200 units total but with the combination
you get less wood and less wheat or less
understory crop per acre
but together says 140 units total
and at the bottom of the left column
it's
it's a it's a greater yield per acre in
total so
two acres whereas you have 200 units
here you get
280 units here um so 140
over yield
examples of this um they're really
tangible for folks uh
polonia so empress polonie tomatosa and
wheat
and i guess other other understory grain
crops in china
um there's some really good data
oh pulling um a few data points or
talking points out of that
with rows of trees 130 to 160 feet apart
or so depending on the crop and the year
um it would it yielded 99 to 104 percent
of the control yield
so by planting trees they actually
increased crop yields between
corn wheat soy and cotton mostly with uh
wheat just because it's it's a t3
and um or plant and it's less
zero sum than corn uh which is c4 in
terms of sunlight
um that's at the latitude of like the
border of south and north carolina but i
believe it as the climate more like
missouri just because they have these
cold fronts that come down from siberia
another one of these i guess over
yield
common systems is silvopasture so
a combination of trees forage and
livestock
um data points here on hot days in
kentucky
cattle gains 60 more weight when they
have access to tree shade
or produce 20 more milk so that's a big
bump in production
there are 200 000 acres of this in the
north of argentina
i visited some of that in 2015.
they actually grow yerba mate there too
so it's kind of a
wood and mate or wood and cattle
situation they also have the
the mono crops of all those um the bump
in yield from the trees
um not the bump so the increased
economic returns from
trees at wider spacing arises because
when you have trees really close
together they grow up
as kind of spindly pulpwood thin logs
that you can't really mill into any
economically meaningful amount of lumber
but when the trees have more space you
get fatter logs and
you go from producing pulp wood to
producing saw logs
um so it's not just
over yield of ag products it's over
yield of
income um and how do we communicate
that over yield of income over
the 30 plus years that an agroforestry
system
is going to be
a working farm and we touched a little
on a little bit a bit of that in a
snapshot
but what we use is modern financial
analysis
to value tree crops um
and so if i guess
these are these are the main
topics titles there's a slide on each
um the time value of money
we have to ask what is so
what dollars is worth to us today
versus that same hundred dollars
received to us in ten years
is different because now
it's available for use so it's kind of
it works into the opportunity cost of
having or not having
dollars in value um and with the time
value of money
we can express say in 20 20 dollars
in a dollar a day what is it worth to us
if we were to earn a hundred dollars in
2030 or if we earn 10
every year between now and 2030 what is
that worth to us in today's dollars and
when valuing tree crops that's something
that is totally imperative um
to communicate their value so if we add
all of those net income
we'll say bottom of the of the
spreadsheet uh add up all of their their
present values that's the net present
value of the system
um if we were to borrow money from the
bank
to let's say uh
opera operational expenditures of a
system
um the internal rate of return is the
interest rate
that the bank would have to charge to
eat up all of our profits
so happy to explain more of that um in
the q a if need be
but it's the the greater the irr the
better um
and this this sort of analysis
what was i guess not surprising but kind
of reassuring to us
is that it's applicable across
socioeconomic groups
even for say subsistence farmers um who
are growing food because it's
it might not be return on it might
not be dollar return on the time but it
might be sick caloric return on time
um and all of this kind of discounting
process is applicable and to any
sort of yield be that pounds calories
dollars nutrients etc
so just a few more examples of over
yields this is a poplar silvopasture
system that i got to visit
in argentine patagonia a few years ago
it's it they're in a wood scarce place
so it makes sense for them to grow
that just run-of-the-mill
type of timber and then argentina is a
big beef producing country so cattle in
the understory this one's in
it's kind of like uh northern new mexico
the climate there here's some
chestnut silver pasture in eastern
kentucky they're just really using the
cattle as lawn mowers
chestnuts are the main value crop there
and just takeaways here
feel free to screenshot this if you want
um
just to succinctly
review kind of what we've we've just
gone gone through um
both the trees and the understory have
to
create positive economic returns for
over yield to occur
um clarifying on that
saying that we can grow something in the
understory is is
say excuse me that we can combine a
treat over story with an understory
is much more relevant when
the trees and the understory are both
profitable
in a way that aligns with the context of
the land manager
and how we've chosen to operate in this
department
is just to make tree crop agronomy
as agronomy for annual grains and
livestock production is so we're
spurring familiarity in order to make
trees a bankable asset
i'm just gonna take a breather here have
some hydration
so um i actually live up in trumansburg
um so for a lot of folks on
the webinar today um that's
super close to them it's about 12 miles
north of ithaca
i actually moved to this region to the
finger lakes because of the presence of
agroforestry
that's already here so a few farms that
are doing it really
well the finger lake cider house you can
see apples and asparagus here
um it's a
we'll say it's a it's it's
one of the most beautiful agroforestry
sites in temperate climate north america
that's masquerading as a cider house so
if you haven't been up there
uh highly recommended go walk around
have some cider and food
peaches in the summer pick your own
they do thanksgiving turkeys so the the
turkeys actually
decrease pest damage from asparagus
beetle to an economically meaningful
extent
and decrease the pest load um
from uh on on the peaches on the fruit
so it's not just
uh selling meat but actually making the
fruit system work a whole lot more
um you pick strawberries you can see the
turkeys and
the apples in the background another one
is well wellspring forest farm so steve
and liz gabriel
um what they've done is is
super interesting how they thin kind of
existing
early successional forest feeding things
like honeysuckle and buckthorn to sheep
and then actually
getting more in what was uh undervalued
kind of shrubland they also do shiitake
mushrooms and ducks
um and then this is actually underneath
a maple canopy you can see the tubing in
the background
then thirdly angus and fauna ripken's
glenn uh this is black locust black
walnut silver pasture brett chedzoy was
a peace corps
volunteer i believe in the early 90s
um or maybe
he came back and on his family's former
dairy farm
planted silver pasture because saw that
saw silva pasture in argentina and now
has
a hundred head of cattle on 300 acres
um he's also converting
uh existing forest into silvopasture
doing it really well so maintaining the
health of the trees so not
set stocking and trampoline the roots
um and it's a really beautiful landscape
uh
the cattle come in during hot days um
and eat
everything in the understory um
recently i'm just gonna time check okay
yep we're doing well
um what's been interesting for us
um saskatoon service berry
it's
a great tasting berry it's
less acid than blueberries uh more
floral flavor ripens two to four weeks
earlier than blueberries or currants
um and so for you pick purposes
this this farm right here is called
juneberry farm it's actually up in ovid
they also do pick your own so if you're
in the area highly recommended um
guy his name is he's a great guy
to go and hang out with as well um so
service very what's interesting
you can use the same mechanical
harvester for
blackcurrant serviceberry aronia maybe
beach plum
and whatnot so basically staggering the
harvest and
um better distributing that capital
expenditure
over different crops in different times
another one um
actually connected with larry smart of
cornell
on this front biomass willow kind of
with the cost of petroleum
as being a substitute right now
it's not often profitable um to grow
willow for
chips and then burn it for energy but
feeding
that willow to cattle um can actually
offset hay costs has a
reasonable lower maintenance return
especially for riparian zones
so riparian are kind of low-lying
um saturated soil that would otherwise
get pugged
pugging is when kind of cows punch
through the soil with their hooves
um so if fill the wet spots with willow
have the cattle eat it
in say the late fall or winter
uh as in say
that thaw cycle so it's harder to do
winter grazing cattle can't use their
horns or their nose or their hooves to
brush off the snow um like they can in
montana or something like that so having
that
biomass that food above ground is is a
great substitute for hay
what's upcoming and interesting for us
are i'll give two examples of this so i
guess two
three things here um c buckthorn
it's a nutraceutical super potent um
yeah there are three million acres of it
across um
rus so siberia mongolia china
we're curious in how to best mechanize
it
and what the returns are for growing it
in this climate or kind of
over into wisconsin and minnesota
another thing that's upcoming is looking
at across
latitudes and geographies what's the
optimal number of acres of silvopasture
that a farm
would do well to plant so uh
how many how how many hot days are there
so how many days
over a certain heat index that's one
input cell we'll say and then how
the herd how many animal units how much
dry matter do they need
on those hot days and then forge species
in the understory cool versus warm
season grasses c3 c4
um and so how do we make the data sets
from different
latitudes and places talk um to forecast
optimal number of acres in silver
pasture same deal with wind breaks
there's another photo from argentina on
the left um
just uh i mean it's it's a photo of me
but if you look at the background
of these farms these windbreak systems
it's it's pretty impressive um so the
questions that we want to answer are
how often are
[Music]
wind up how much weight gain how much
weight loss do we have and then what are
the costs in the revenues of
managing a windbreak over 30 years and
we're coming up on time
um so just takeaways agroforestry
creates over yields
um uses time value money to elucidate
the financial value of perennial ag
and then de-risking trees creates trees
as a bankable asset
so um hopefully we didn't go over too
much but
yeah that's that's the scoop um
hopefully we have some
some time for q a
so um i will ask anyone in the audience
if they have questions for harry
and if people would prefer they can
certainly put
their questions in the chat box
and yep harry you did just what i was
about to ask
um which is getting off the shared
screen
so questions from anyone in the audience
markets or some of these crops in the
northeast yeah um
so holes from michael snow um
markets for some of these crops we'll
say
chestnuts there's a lot of demand from
recent immigrants so
um koreans palestinians chinese etc more
in the urban areas
um selling retail prices drastic differ
pretty drastically
um black currant is really an ingredient
fruit americans aren't super familiar
with it
so i mean in in terms of black currant
in a product that has the similar
quality of minute made
um we you think have things like grape
juice but say black currant in
beer wine etc that's a bit more
interesting
and then black locust decking
is a substitute for the synthetic
decking
uh so first lasts for
20 years if you want black locust
decking right now most of it's imported
actually from europe
um so processing are existing processors
for a lot of things like
oh we'll say off-season apple
infrastructure for juicing different
fruits that fruit earlier in the year
um juicing fermenting refrigerating
transporting um
we like to look at rented space
and not spending more on newer capital
expenditures that are necessary
there's actually a black locust mill in
ithaca newfield
uh black locust lumber i believe it's
called but
we model everything for different
regions with
a custom sawyer coming on process coming
on farm
um so yeah
how small is the minimum land for an
agroforestry project
um say if a farmer wanted to beef up the
riparian buffers on his or her farm
from 30 feet to 100 feet wide and
convert it to agroforestry to maintain
economic return
um minimum land for an agroforestry
project um
totally depends on the crop type so like
one acre of blueberry you
pick would totally work out
um if we define agroforestry as just
diversifying with perennials
um it scales up and scales down really
well uh we
oh the smallest farm we're working on is
30 acres of growing space
yeah i mean converting buffer um
and agro4 is is pretty reasonable
it's it's just the cost of taking land
out of production and like say if you
have to buy hay
next question what is the highest number
of crop species you use in an
agroforestry system
um it looks like there's only one
species and some of the some of the
systems
association rotation without
complicating management too much great
question um so it depends if we're going
for
insect fungal plant diversity etc um
say every tenth row is it
is a row of biodiversity um
and then those insects can fly into
the um the system so we'll
i mean it's it what we highlight maybe
three
core economic species but the
biodiversity species are
i don't want to say unlimited but maybe
up to 12
and that's a lot of that's based on what
the xerxes society says
are are good species for a region for
insects
um do you have a general process to
follow in determining what species and
plants to put on a farm how site
specific do you get
when picking plant communities very
site-specific
uh um a lot of that has to do with
not just the biogeophysical climate but
also
the climate between the ears of
a set of farm managers um
so what works for their lifestyle and
their land and their current system and
what they want to manage
um so there's a there's a long process
of holistic context development there
all right from sam speak to the
experience of
propagate finding research on
agroforestry systems in the northeast
and how an institution like cornell
could help advance agroforestry
um finding research on airport
what we do on that front is dive into a
lot of
university and ngo white papers on
different crops
and say read four by 75 pages
synthesize that info and make text
cornell is great for that with new crops
coming online so grad students
writing up a uh
there's there's one establi just top of
mind establishing organic flat currents
in maritime canada
it's like the more you dig the more you
find
um so definitely keep going in that
front
for mel what amount of supply is there
for crops like these
in terms of nursery presence there is an
elephant in the room
in the nursery world because a bunch of
nurseries have
frankly retired so
efficient nurseries growing
a lot of these crops is definitely an
opportunity
the nursery hustle is very real going
out and finding
different nurseries some that have
unique genetics aren't necessarily the
easiest to order for
from ordering trees is not like ordering
off of amazon
um is there any income generated for by
incorporating plant nurseries into your
systems
with plants that can be harvested for
cuttings like
willow and blackcurrant it's a
possibility um but that's not our core
focus
right now though it can be all right
from
james mentioned black walnut
agroforestry in missouri
example using multi-purpose trees to
offset long-term econ
of growing boards any other examples of
multi-purpose trees in the north
um
other ice if james if you could just
follow up on that one
um with just a little bit of
clarification there um
and then from peter woodbury can you
talk about examples or plans for
building up marketing
and supply chains yes definitely um
i'll give two examples of buyers um
brewery and supplements brand and an
egg brand so pastured organic raised
organic
egg brand wants to diversify their
pastures because they can't grow crops
but they can grow trees that the
chickens integrate into
and then say breeze
interested in buying different fruit um
for their beer supplements brand
interested in elderberry
so how do we create that stack paulie
stevenson
do you use any forestry management
techniques to assist in land management
i.e prescribed burning
invasive species management forestry
mulching is a big one so that's like a
wood chipper on the front of either a
bobcat or a bulldozer
um prescribed burning is
oh one of our farms in maryland did that
um
and we haven't done that as a company
yet
it is it's on it's on it's on tap
um we're very interested in prescribed
burning
um just as an alternative to tillage all
right mark phillips
what are good agroforestry pathways for
diversified organic veg farms
um i would say things that
already use the existing refrigeration
and processing infrastructure
so small fruit is a good one
if i'll put this in the chat here
can i do that to send chat to
everyone okay
nope uh la doret is a market garden
and fruit combo
in the south that's doing that really
well and then
not stein do you work at all with
agri-voltaic like incorporating solar
panels of livestock
um in the pipeline as well uh there's a
big
uh very very large solar system that has
sheep underneath it
in the southeast u.s um
that they they have extra land where it
didn't make sense to put solar panels
but they want to do the same thing and
they see
they they see that value analog between
solar and trees
um so yes on that if if someone's
grazing solar then it's it's a it's a
good fit to then
go from solar pasture to silvo pasture
um helloagriculture.com would a
greenhouse space be required for plant
nursery
or open feed um it helps just to de-risk
uh weather events for sure uh
greenhouses are great
um we've seen people grow blueberries
and raspberries and peaches
underneath high tunnels for frost
protection and whatnot and just
season extension um so hopefully that
answered
that question also what about herbs and
medicinal
plants integrated in your operations is
that profitable um
if there's a market for it and the
processing works out
um and it fits with the context
definitely
one of the interesting ones there is
schisandra vine
i haven't modeled it yet but i would i
would love to um
herbs and medicinal plants we get a lot
of questions about hemp um
but as i'm sure a lot of
folks have seen it's it's been a big
boom and bust crop
um so we
we thankfully avoided getting uh
pulled into the cbd craze um
yeah i've been i've been i've been
talking a bunch but any any other
questions what
how are we doing on time um a few more
minutes
so if there were more questions we would
be able to
accommodate them i have a question
yeah thank you so much for this talk it
was really
awesome um and marvin pritz gave
an introduction to a lot of these
lesser-known berry
crops uh in our berry production class
today so it was super cool to see
how they're being economically
integrated um
you talked a lot about the economics of
um
these integrated agroforestry systems
how how does um carbon sequestration
kind of fit in to all this with you were
saying you're trying to reduce
tillage um and have you modeled any of
uh the carbon sequestration
and long-term uh benefits
yeah the um the carbon itself with trees
feels really easy to ah but so it's
easier to model and have an input cell
for the price of carbon but um assuring
what that price of carbon will be is the
hardest part so the
the um i wrote an article about this
the economic reality of
aggro ecology um
that's the title that dives into a
deeper version of this but
there are a few ways that that works out
really well
or carbon payments the way we're
addressing this
is via kind of creating those ecosystem
services as a positive externality
so just doing it anyway and the crops
make the econ work out the other one is
having a municipality
not a carbon market so a single buyer
pay for ecosystem services be those
carbon or water quality payments
the ecosystem services markets in the us
are generally underdeveloped
so we do definitely keep tabs on them um
but we're not necessarily holding our
breath right now
and one other question
i see from michael snow how can we find
equipment for
mechanizing these operations yeah
so um
for for berries in particular
that's what you want to google um it's
basically shrub fruit mechanization
another question that we always ask is
how do we model systems to use
readily available equipment that farmers
already have
to manage these systems so
we want to go out and buy another 20 000
piece of machinery so how do we use a
rotary rake
integrated into an agroforestry system
it's a basic hanging implement that
everyone has
or like a bail chopper to mulch um
so yeah that's that's a that's a fun
rabbit hole in mechanization
um and then from holly stevenson do you
ever model your systems after
other types of ecosystems like savannahs
or prairies
definitely on savannahs and prairies um
so wide silver pasture spacing kind of
mimics that that that
sparse tree um system and then
wide wide spacing for alley cropping
for grain might also mimic that
so harry based on the number of
questions that came in
in the chat i would say that there was a
great deal
of interest in your subject
and uh your methods and uh
also we had a terrific turnout today
uh so late in the semester so i want to
thank you
for sharing uh so much about
how your firm is not only working today
but also looking to the future
fantastic yeah and i guess
dawn and sam and catalina thank you so
much
for hosting um we really appreciate the
opportunity
uh to to come in and um
share what we're up to with everyone um
my email is just harry
propagateventures.com
um welcome anyone to follow up there or
on social media or just propagate
ventures on facebook and instagram
um i believe this not asked
if this is being recorded yes i think it
will be up on youtube
i'm not sure when exactly um
but yeah that that'll uh
that'll be available to go back and
maybe decipher things that i've said
quickly
or it will be available i can't tell you
quite how soon but it will be on
the section of horticulture website
so thanks again harry and um farewell
to all of you from the fall semester
and we will hope to see you again in
february
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu